so my name is jaime menderson i'm a
professor at the stanford business
school
and i specialize in electronic business
business models and technology more
broadly
um before i did my phd i worked for
about
seven years in the computing
activities of the israeli army
where i was in charge of developing very
large scale systems
and they learned a lot about information
technology from that
in parallel i was doing my phd in
computer science and operations research
on related subjects and then i started
teaching
uh uh in the information systems area
i came to stanford about 23 years ago
in the business school and i've been
teaching
information technology a and
business related subjects since then
so we started doing electronic commerce
electronic business in the business
school
before the terms even existed and i
remember at the time we started
that the students were asking what is
why are we talking about the internet
who cares about the internet i mean we
want to talk about business
and today people realize that it's
actually important so it's a little
easier to do that
so when you think about the area of
electronic business the intersection of
technology and business
i think it is a the most exciting area
that actually exists today because this
is an area
where we have an opportunity to totally
change the world
and it's not a theoretical opportunity
it's a very practical opportunity
lots of things are happening and many of
the choices
that we're going to make today are
actually going to
have to make a big difference so this is
an opportunity to have an
impact and to have that impact at the
very very large scale
and i think opportunities like that
never existed before
and don't exist in any other area
to me innovation is a combining
things that existed before
in new ways that create value
in a way that didn't exist before so if
you think about
amazon.com when it was founded
they didn't have any fundamental
innovation what they did was put
together the capability
to put together a website and to sell on
the web and to have payments on the web
and to do logistics all of these are
elements that existed
but they combined them to create a
business model
that never existed before
so if we think about the way to to have
the most impact on the world
it depends on the area we work on and i
think i'm fortunate working in an area
where we can have a huge amount of
impact
but it's also a function of where you do
that
and so stanford is important because
that's where
innovation comes from an intellectual
point of view from a research point of
view
in silicon valley is where these ideas
are translated into practice
so we are very fortunate to be in the
place
where the ideas are being formed and
they're being put into practice
you